un autre visage une autre voie celle
d'une artiste de hong kong denise ho
retenez bien ce nom parce que c'est
l'une des très rares personnalités à
oser s'afficher en faveur de la lutte
pour la démocratie
pour elle il n'y a pas de retour en
arrière possible
il faut continuer de défier le géant
chinois dit elle malgré les risques de
l'iso a grandi au québec c'est
d'ailleurs ici qu elle s'est imprégnée
des valeurs de démocratie et de liberté
nous l'avons jointe à hong kong
ces deux
[Musique]
si c'est dans
ça
ligne 1
denisot bonsoir à vous encore le soir
d'abord dites moi quel est l'état
d'esprit des gens à hong kong après une
autre fin de semaine de manifestations
on n'est pas satisfait ça c'est le
situation ici et puis on a eu beaucoup
de folie la brutalité de la police
depuis les trois mois
et puis on n'a pas de moyens pour pour
trouver la justice contre cette
brutalité que car il a offert donc le
retrait de ce projet de loi sur
l'extradition
c'est pour vous c'est trop peu trop tard
oui à les gens sont pop content et donc
oui oui de wanted faux at least
peut-être vous maintenez vos demandes
mais la période de transition elle se
termine en 2047
alors est ce que le fameux principe un
pays deux systèmes est ce que la fin de
ce principe n'est pas inévitable si
chaque saut du tarn vous défier quand
même un des gouvernements les plus
puissants de la planète la chine
combien de temps vous pouvez tenir
denise rietsch everything i do
randy
ce cas
[Musique]
e
et ça
ce
oussama
parlons de vous maintenant parce qu'en
tant qu'artiste vous avez quand même
payer très cher votre engagement
politique
jusqu'où êtes vous prête personnellement
à les temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis tout ce temps qu on vient de le
voir vous avez confrontée la chine aux
nations unies vous avez été interrompue
deux fois par le représentant chinois
est-ce que vous avez été surprise de
cette réaction des pics vous n'êtes pas
senti intimidé amin'ny
[Musique]
quoi
m
[Musique]
c
vous avez grandi au québec vous avez
étudié ici est-ce que vous avez gardé
des liens
j'ai passé mon adolescence ici
j'habitais à brossard quand j'étais à
montréal
donc c'est une très belle souvenir je me
sentais pas isolé même si je t'ai
asiatiques et puis j'étais je suis de la
cupidité lgbt et mais même j'ai reçu
beaucoup de de chaleur des amis de
montréal donc je suis toujours en
contact avec mes amis qu'est ce qui vous
reste au fond de toutes ces années
passées à montréal qu'est ce que ça a
changé chez vous mais surtout ma façon
de regarder la vie et puis ma vie audi
a6 donc je me sens toujours que montréal
et ou de mon coeur donc je suis fier
d'être mondiale et canadienne denisot
merci beaucoup
quelle voie suivre bien sûr la situation
à hong kong de près